I think the US automakers are so big and
so important it's very difficult for the
government to just a idly by and watch
them die but I think it's very important
to learn for the future what were the
mistakes and how do we avoid them what
are the systemic lessons we can learn
and I think one extremely important
aspect is the legacy costs today every
car sold is burdened not only by the
cost to produce it the steel the labor
put into it but the price tag must also
include costs for those 70 and eight
year old people worked in those
industries 10 20 30 years ago and those
costs were not paid by those support
course at that time they are paid by the
people by course today and the reason is
that in the United States you have
chosen to have corporate based social
security in practice I think that is
old-fashioned it's on modern it is a
hinder for flexibility a Hindu for
growth and it is a very bad burden on
competitiveness and I believe this is
the most important lesson of this crisis
in the car industry to do something
about for the future that cannot be
addressed in the short term but it's a
systemic negative element in the
American economy and it tells me that
the story about the American economy
being so flexible that that story is if
not miss it is at least grossly
exaggerated this is something that locks
up labor in individual companies it
makes movement between different
industries more difficult and in today's
globalized economy change is the key to
success flexibility rapid adaption 22
changed competitive pressures change
technologies and
that's extremely important